you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm uh just got
paired up I play a 15-2 game at the
white pieces let's start with Knight f3
see what black throws at us okay then
let's go with c4 let's see what black
goes into okay some type of Indian 9c3
and maybe we're gonna get something
different
playing I played last 15 - game it was a
king's indian I don't even know how to
pronounce that variation Kaz something
with a knight a 6-1 once again play this
let's see if we could get a different
variation maybe we'll get to see a
variation with E 5 mm once again doing
e4 here to avoid the an opportunity for
black to play the Grunfeld so castles
Bishop e2 the moment of truth Knight a6
or e5 something else
okay e5 alright so this was my intention
to capture and then get the Queen's off
let's let's try an ending and I'm really
gonna try my best to make it the case
right do not live off of the increment
so let's take the Queen that a little
click to click I rarely ever use that
just clicking from square to square to
move the pieces but uh anyhow this is
all so for pretty well-known stuff after
Bishop here there's this is maybe the
most common reply to secure this e5 pawn
there's also c6 I think
so let's see what black does hmm they're
thinking I wonder if
they are unfamiliar with this position
that could be good news for me
so we'll see what they come up with I'm
threatening to capture on e5 and on rook
to e8 I could follow up with Knight d5
and you know that you're pretty much
forced into taking the night rook e8 95
because I'm hitting at c7 and f6
so what's black and to do on c6 I could
take the pawn okay we're not having that
on c6 Knight takes pawn I could show it
afterwards if I remember c6 Knight takes
pawn rook here and then queenside castle
all right so let's follow up and pretty
move that Knight takes Knight pretty
much locked in to having to take
pressure on f6 and c7 c6 I could play
Bishop c4 its defend d5 I want to be
able to recapture with the piece and
then this is where it could get pretty
complicated for sure there's b5 here b5
Bishop back and then a 5 maybe Bishop d7
stuff ok they're captured right away hmm
so with this in position to take with
the piece and I'm not sure what I want
to do with my King just yet I don't know
if I mean I could queenside castle
that's something I wanted to just point
out right away I could queenside castle
mmm King to eat
I don't know if the position is
simplified enough where I could play
King to e to like a knight maybe one day
coming in here some pin and this
diagonal so I'm not sure if my king
would want to go to e2 if the light
square bishops are exchanged I could
pretty much rely upon the e2 squares a
as a good home for my king okay so this
is really the first moment that I'm
having to think a little bit let's see
what to do here
my first thought is to simply queenside
castle
hmm this is uh what can I expect here
okay oh that's summer some of the
thoughts I'm having right now are that I
really would not I want to I want to
play this position in a way where this
dark square bishop is never given the
opportunity to exchange himself off for
anything I want to play against this
dark square bishop in other words I want
to play against this relationship
between the bishop and the fixed pawn on
e5 he's though the worst placed piece I
could take the knight and damage the
black Queen side structure but I am
investing the bishop hair to do that I
don't know that that's such a wise
choice huh if I'm not careful Knight be
for it could be annoying hitting my
bishop and getting into c2 um let's see
candidate moves include queenside castle
on queenside castle there's Bishop g4
that could be a little bit of a pain
hmm what I would really like to have
happen on both nights exchange in both
the light square bishop six changes bad
bishop ending I'd really like to have
that happen if I queenside castle Bishop
g4 that I must say is a bit of a pain
that pin and queenside castle night b4 I
think I would just calmly retreat to b3
off of any open files queenside castle
Bishop g4 maybe at that moment I take
the knight I don't know it's a tough
call over here's another thought Bishop
e3 mm no night before the pain oh you
know what I think I need to do queenside
castling on Bishop g4 I think I played
Bishop III anticipating that well I
cannot rely upon my f3 Knight anymore to
defend e4 this is the weakest point in
my position so I need to take good care
of it like one way this Bishop could be
brought to life as a knight once he
plants up here some exchange pawn takes
this bishop maybe turns out to be well I
said earlier the least valuable
currently but with this pawn on e5 if
it's converted to a deep on it's a world
of difference
supporting then a passed pawn opens up
this file for the rook a lot of good
happens but hmm my bishop still has to
be it must be a pain though this night
is over here I still have pressure on b7
so hmm by the ten-minute mark I said I
didn't want to live off the increment I
think I devoted enough time here let's
let's carry on let's carry on with
development who could argue with that
really and I'm expecting Bishop g4 I
would really welcome seeing Bishop e6 I
would welcome my bad bishop mmm bad
bishop just related to my pawn structure
but it's what we might call a very
active bad Bishop can't really do one
better I don't know that there's a
really a better Square for my bishop my
LightSquared Bishop then d5 right now
it's a reliable home
it's defended well it's radiating in
both the directions c7 could there's
some lines where maybe if a rook gets to
the seventh rank it starts to be well
coordinated converging at f7 rook and
Bishop
so what mores not gonna do I'm pretty
much you know what I'm gonna do a night
before I think he's just going in the
wrong direction that's just a one move
threat I back up and it's he doesn't
have a good reply to the two-word test
which is now what you know what do you
what's the big follow-up after night
before so I'm thinking Bishop g4 Bishop
g4 I'm gonna play Bishop III I don't
think that there's a a good reason to
have my
Bishop's staring at this d8 square
anymore
so I'm gonna I'm gonna return him here
to e3 on Bishop g4 I could end up with a
damaged structure that's true who could
even see an officer colored bishop
pending Bishop g4 Bishop III
yeah bishop
for Bishop III Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Knight d4 I think I have to snap
him off right away although you can't go
94 right away let me let me step back
here for a moment you can't quickly jump
in for that variation in giving up the
lights for a bishop for my knight and
then my my dark square Bishop taking out
a knight on d4 because I do have this
pressure still on b7 so black I'm sure
is trying to figure out a way to
successfully coordinate or I should say
complete development you know he's got
to be a bug here that guy in d5 I know
if I'm de I can't flip the board right
now but I was able to flip the board I
know that this is this bishop would be a
giant pain to me okay I'm not sure what
other candidate well I was here's
something I would really like to see h6
this would be a case of kicking my
bishop to a square I would already want
to go to so this is helping me age six
what other moves are being considered
rook e8 that seems too slow to babysit
upon to eventually go in for this you
know another thing if the bishop doesn't
play here right away I might want to
play a move like h3 rule it out
altogether
mmm some slow improving moves Oh some
slow improving those were baking to be
won
well I wasn't lying when I thought that
this
I didn't think black would have a good
follow up after night b3 all right after
Bishop to b3 what's the what's the big
story here not really seeing it let's
wait a moment
Bishop b3 Bishop e6 Bishop takes Bishop
now this isn't good this really isn't
going anywhere as far as I could tell
let's back up just try to stay on pace
with my opponents time I guess I guess
if I'm gonna live off the increment I
better make sure my opponents living off
of the increment so Bishop e6 Bishop
takes rook takes I could play a3 there's
a rook check King b1 and a knight uncie
- I think he's going in the wrong
direction maybe even running the risk of
getting trapped or at the very least
we'll have a knight exchange and oh well
we could quickly see an ending that I'm
uh I'd be very very comfortable with one
where it's my good Bishop versus this
bad bishop so the only logical follow-up
I could see - maybe just a finite to be
for maybe a5 a4 is an idea I don't think
so a5 a3 a4 I could play here that might
be weird that's pretty wild
actually what I could do on a5 I could
play Bishop a4 okay we are having this
trade so Bishop takes rook takes
otherwise this is a very ugly structure
and now with the light square Bishop s'
exchanged I could get to the seventh
rank so this starts to be a bit
appealing I think we're going to have
well we're gonna have light square
Bishop scum off Bishop takes follow up
a3 there's gonna be a check King be one
night see - that's a bit scary it's just
barely hanging together
Black's I'd think eventually has to jump
in here if he goes to see to eventually
be forced in here I could take and then
I'd this pond could very well turn out
to be a liability classic case of upon
being overextended more of a liability
as fewer pieces or as more pieces are
exchanged as a fewer pieces are on the
board that could be a liability get my
king at like in a strictly pawn bishop
ending this good Bishop versus bad
bishop if there's if this pawn is on d4
he'll be scooped up in short order my
king is very quick towards the center
that's another nice feature in this more
simplified ending so let's start with
the more direct stuff what to do in this
exact position those are just some
general considerations hmm Bishop takes
I don't see any other I don't see any
other move I don't want to allow the
double isolated pawns so and I want to
immediately kick this Knight out of
there this is the get out of my house
move yeah let's do it here hmm I could
consider just king b1 any big difference
between a three or king b1
I have a check that's silly though no
good reason to do that I want to play
here
yeah I'm not I don't think I can be one
now get out of there he needs to get out
of my house get out of my house they get
out of my house move get out of my side
of the board let's let's make black come
up with something here will there be a
check or an immediately an immediate run
to c6 Knight c6 to d4 and I'm not sure
which rook would give check probably the
one that's not playing yet although I
don't know how well this rook stands
okay so I'm so far pretty happy with the
position I have one other nice features
that win this bishop maybe relocates to
e3 I'll be observing a7 which needs to
be tended to sometimes you could allow
this to be captured and then you know
get the rook back over here and after
the bishop moves you get a pond on the a
file but I have this at pawn up to a3 so
this is it this would be a genuine
threat once my bishops on e3 so this
Bishop is a still needs to do something
that's this is the problem piece that I
was not expecting okay that is
officially a sidelined Knight and my
first thought is to keep him sidelined
yes
let's wait a moment no no no let's not
wait a moment
hang on there is a moment here to think
I have other choices rook d7 now no no
no no no I need to stop in the knife
from getting here I don't want to play
this too quick on this move I don't
necessarily have to react to pawn takes
pawn because I have like moves like
Knight g5 with
hitting the rook and the pond and you
don't necessarily even have to go in
that direction there's uh you know
Knight d2 to e4 so okay so Blackie's are
doing something about getting this
trying to eliminate that push up now on
b4 this might be struck at at some point
with a5 so my first thought is to play
rook here I should probably do that why
not
I'm a dual-purpose move primary function
to defend against c5 I don't want to
allow this Knight along all this Bishop
to trade itself off I'm also throwing a
punch at E 5 any Czech pretty much can
be won automatically and ready to maybe
play rook do you want or c1 on seeing I
might want to trade a little bit this is
still something Black has to tend to and
putting a piece here now this could be a
pin black isn't careful this could be a
pin and win very easily see the loss of
material if to keep this in mind it's a
possibility Knight g5 that's nice
forward move with tempo striking at the
rook f7 which again we're saying it
earlier with my bishop on the board f7
being a bit soft similarly with this
Knight leap into g5 also if this bishop
gets excited about going elsewhere maybe
I could plant my bishop here on h6 and
renew back rank possibilities so I like
this position due to having the better
bishop currently and maybe in some sense
having the safer King this is certainly
a reliable home a light square as a
flight square although I don't know I
don't know if I would even want to go
here
if the rooks are off the board I'll be
flying in towards the center very
quickly I have a better King position
let's black gonna come up with if they
play f6
hmm they play f6 I could forget about
night here I might want to think about
rerouting my night like right away like
d2 stuff hmm I think d2 may be b3 to
defend here and I here also to allow my
f this F 3 move anticipating some night
on c5 arriving to hitting this pond
he is unprotected who's like this won't
work like runs right into nine to d2 I'm
ahead on the clock ah I was just saying
what this move does it runs right into
92 so I think that this is a super
valuable tempo in fact I could take this
pawn but this is just just crying out
for this room another thing is I'm on
this take this pawn
oh this could this can't even be taken I
have a fork Forks okay should ice should
I grab that pond should I snatch that
pond there of interesting possibilities
I want to try and keep this as clean as
possible I don't want to allow any
counter play do not allow complications
oh wait a second rook here King here
would be needed hmm now that is maybe
something I just feel like I'm going in
the wrong direction Bishop takes b6 and
then I have to kind of like rescue my
bishop doesn't seem like the right
direction to go in
hmm rook here threatens Bishop h6 rooked
rook b8 King here would be needed I
don't see what the great
is for me after that Robbie for just uh
rule out any uh any stuff with a piece
coming here it's a bit scary though some
sacrifices here rooks coming over I
don't know if that's ever really working
this is a very simple approach night
determined falling behind on the clock
its time flew right by it really did
well I'm gonna keep it really simple I'm
gonna do this seeing anything I'm not
I'm doing this so I could play my night
to be three I want to defend here with a
piece and then just finished my
development
everything should be tucked in quite
nicely
pretty soon night night b3 Brooke hd1 I
should rattle off those moves pretty
quick
let's see where the rook goes I'm
expecting some retreat to let's say the
seventh rank maybe completely back so
nighttime b3 is interesting just have it
functioning to defend c5 using piece
play to defend c5 and who knows maybe
one day he jumps into a five so night b3
and then double rooks is the idea and he
have five move up lay up three all right
let's get there defend c5 oh maybe this
one oh I was thinking Brooke b6 to hit
by night it's not allowed I was thinking
for a moment right here to go there oh
okay this is a very welcome sight let's
double up I'd really like to see peace
get here now so we could have minor
pieces exchanged quickly but then I
still have some advantage in the form of
pawn structure at the end if this pawn
has to capture their split
of course if it's a rook only ending
those uh kinda quite often turn out to
be a draw but alright how can we move
forward here let's let's get some trades
and this is a nice consolidating move
yeah I'm gonna do this I missing
anything
it's a lot of sneaky stuff like here and
that's not quite working I'm gonna do
this I want to keep some pressure on
this pawn still I don't wanna I don't
want to leave I was gonna do this but I
want to keep pressure here this rook
still has he's struggling a bit
was this Knight do hmm alright it's a
nail-biter to clockwise even ish you're
gonna give me that advantage notice if
there's a pawn here they're split and it
paves the way for my King to enter right
away alright
they're repositioning their nightwear to
exactly I don't even know maybe I could
think about Bishop here reposition my
bishop to a more active square I'd
really like to see them weak in their
seventh rank let's let's try this my
bishop on c3 however I need to be a bit
careful of some tricks on any three
Bishop takes 83 pawn takes and then you
know that's that sort of stuff some
tactics on 83 my pawn on b2 is
essentially overloaded as soon as my
bishops on c3 so I know f6 could defend
this pawn but that would weaken the
second rank or yeah they're second rank
both under three now hmm I think my
knight well I should probably reposition
mine okay yeah they're they're stopping
any of that last a couple moves I'm not
too happy about how I played it
um should I trade a Brook Oh is there
any trick I don't know what I want to I
don't want to do this anymore let's get
back here hmm
anticipating like night here I want to
make sure I keep control over d4 so I
had to take a little u-turn there now oh
okay
my idea was this it straight a little
bit I don't want to allow the rook to
get the second ring let's trade a little
bit and if takes how do I recapture mmm
let's take with my knight I don't think
maybe he could reposition to a more
central square yeah that's that'll be
useful like my rook I'll see all the
mistakes that have been made up to this
point for sure after the game with
stockfish night here he is in fact going
back here isn't he floundering man
all right could I get that night in a
pin let's try this rook here I don't
think my rook is so well placed anymore
in the center I'm going to try to get a
pin here all right let's put them in a
pin I really should get my King active
their King is more active now hmm let's
do this anticipating some Knight move
and some capture here bishop we'll take
that h2 pond the bill gates pawn so the
knight could move yeah so we are having
this alright let's take and pretty sure
I want to get my king working like right
now
soon as possible so big technical phase
here okay
they have upon fixed on the light square
I should probably still move forward
this is a this is my only advantage that
they have this pond fixed on this e5
square still I'm looking to play against
this Bishop okay my knight I no longer
need here let's let's go somewhere else
I would really like to give up my Bishop
for their Knight may be like this move
may be here let's see if I could provoke
some weaknesses Bishop here force this
move and then maybe I could get in g4 if
I do this I'm giving up b4 I'm having a
very difficult time trying to get a good
spot for my knight I got a one minute
warning jump in here maybe what's that
let's get right here watch out for the
tricky Knight he's gonna go back no he's
not
so I get this square with tempo I'll
take it he backs up the boxes me out
pretty nice
about Bishop here was that even do I
don't know what I want to do just make
some active move knight here to here I
could get my Bishop on c3 here Bishop b4
Bishop c3 let's try that is this Knight
ready to be trapped maybe huh
let's go here let's box out that night
34 seconds trade nights let's try this I
don't know Bishop here we'll just go
back and forth a little bit here Bishop
back he's probably a drop but I'll try
to do something okay let's go back here
so much for trying to do something there
I don't see any great way to make
progress here
um we can get a pawn on a light square
maybe I do this at some point
hmm now Knight here might be something
but then Bishop here at the end I'll
have some trade let's get this moving
then here but ship takes
I can't even commentate anymore not here
so I have some opening I think that was
a mistake
King position I should get King position
in here threatening night here and
trading the Knights it's probably still
drawn but I'm gonna I'm gonna try for
something and I hear there's Knight a5
it's thrown a check
let's try and bug them
King here if it goes too far away this
could be a pain bishops tied down if the
Kings no longer here big decision now
let's go here
Knight here I'm gonna back up watch
these two squares let's back up there is
that night check 15 seconds yeah maybe I
should have went all the way back
actually so I have this move let's get
this in mmm it's a bit more it's not as
flexible anymore but you know yeah I
don't see a great way to make progress
Oh what about here okay this is maybe my
moment to enter actually I think that
might have been a mistake let's try and
enter I'm gonna try and mop up these
pawns here gotta go fast hitting the
bishop let's do this and then here
scariness night here I go here get some
try and banks on time let's do this
thing here oh this is a one king of Han
ending I get to trade down now whoo
there go the minor pieces and let's just
grab this pawn this is a one King and
pawn ending pretty sure yeah I have
enough Tempe to outflank black I could
sneak out now and just hunt hunt these
ponds
and I just play this out a little bit I
guess you know we'll see what the
computer has to say after this I'm
pretty sure I had a good position like I
had those Trump's in the form of a
better Bishop but my opponent was
untangling they they get their dark
square Bishop working and as soon as
that happened I think evaluation just
not came there it's the only thing
evaluation probably shifted right around
that moment as soon as they're dark
square Bishop got activated okay they
resigned let me go into analysis mode
here this is a long game 87 moves all
right let's see where we can uh where
were their mistakes here I'm have stock
fish now on my side here so this is all
pretty standard stuff here this is the
one thing I wanted to point out if this
move is played
he could take on this square and after
rook e8 you could castle rook takes
Knight there's rook here and after rook
e8 Bishop takes Knight rook takes rook
Bishop takes rook and White's up a pawn
for really nothing but we didn't have
that instead it was rook here ninety
five takes takes c6 this right here this
is a interesting line with b5 Bishop a 3
and then a 5 there's a a 3 there's a
foreign response I'm not sure which one
is really best computer calls for a4 but
I believe a3 is in another move as well
what could very often happen it gets
quite sharp with black delaying this
capture there could be well he could
turn into a passed pawn and a blink and
tied in with this bishop that could be
quite annoying just to maybe show one
line something like this d6 in fact is
being called for right now and then
after Bishop FA they're saying to
queenside castle I guess there's some
tricks here or they're saying Castle
kingside what's the trick with Bishop
takes pawn here ROKAF d1 nothing nothing
huge huh saying that there's it's just
like a point three advantage there's no
I don't see a great reason to give up
the pawn like that but uh in some lines
if black isn't careful let's just say it
develops the knight this this could be
quite a pain probably has to be
challenged right away with the bishop
here but it could get quite sharp as my
main point if you're not capturing this
deep on another line right here after
Bishop c4 is to play Knight d7 I think
no I'm mistaken
after this capture takes Knight d7 I
think yeah yeah this is this is the this
is the follow up instead of knight c6
this was the move played in the game I
think takes is fine like that but the
follow-up then Knight here IDs of maybe
Knight c5 and the other one is to play
in
here which is threatening to win the
bishop or pawn like if I Castle Knight
f6 right away or maybe even first trying
to kick the bishop away from defending
f6 Bishop here Knight f6 and now I have
to part ways with my light-square bishop
otherwise logically dropping e4 so short
story here is that instead of knight c6
there's 97 as well trying to get in here
on 97 there's now 92 so that on Knight
f6 you could drop back the knight is
there to defend e4 but anyhow knight c6
was played computers calling for
queenside castle I did that night before
what did it like better than night
before actually it likes night before as
a top mount interesting before okay it
like that like that move to of course I
didn't have a lot of options and how
it's coming for a 5 oh I touched on that
briefly I was saying I might want to try
this mmm makes it saying the knight
should be going back now
it's a weird line before with a 5 is the
follow up ok we didn't have that instead
it's Bishop e6 saying about a happen not
even a half pawn advantage sing like
point for advantage for white which is
not a whole lot at all
and yeah it's a trade bishops King b1 it
wants to play but hmm what are the
differences I wonder I was torn between
a3 and King b1 it's no it's about equal
okay Knight back there and that wants to
play b4 hmm just having the pawn watch
over yeah I'm sure it's objectively good
to do it like that but I was trying to
play a bit more practically I guess you
could say having pieces around to defend
c5
I was especially with this ruck still on
his home square if I'm playing b4
there's always some fear of maybe a 5 we
are
I know it's simplified quite a bit now
Queens on the board but it is opposite
sides castling it's still a couple minor
pieces around this rook has some lateral
movement I didn't want to allow for that
sort of strike so oh now it's saying
Bishop III okay
that's a that's nice to see and now
wants to play a5 okay instead I think
black did well with trying to get rid of
their dark square Bishop and just kind
of go a bit faster here it's a lot of
moves in this key but it doesn't like
rook c4 Brooksie for what just wants to
play rook HD one right away
and this Knight g5 but hmm what did I do
I just kicked him away right away still
just about a half pawn advantage and he
I'm just doing a blunder check right now
I have a close eye on the computer
evaluation computer wants to do this but
you know what I was I was in the mindset
right now where I didn't want to do
anything with the structure I wanted to
know I guess you could say work within
the structure I currently have it's a
solid one I didn't want to create any
weaknesses I just wanted to do play with
the the pieces try and get them to
better squares course that's tough to
really manage how these guys are these
guys are on their home squares no
certainly this bishop I've lost track of
what night this is in the game but
anyhow he's on a home square it's
calling for f4 right now but yeah I
wasn't wasn't even thinking about any of
that
no it's like dead even dead even nothing
nothing exciting and then yeah I mean it
really should have been a draw was there
anything I missed I know at the very end
only when there was time pressure was
there an issue where we had just a fine
pieces being exchanged with any blunders
on any of our part before that really oh
right here or something ah right here we
were both living out for the increment
Bishop e7 I played Bishop c5 Bishop e7
yeah
that's sneaky Bishop takes Knight takes
and then this will be a win still tricky
however these guys are around but still
I had an opportunity for that Bishop c5
instead and yet again hmm
Bishop e7 I guess if you don't see it
once there's a good chance you're not
gonna see it again
I don't know how true that is but okay
I'm not sure why I play g4 oh yeah one
of the thoughts I had with g4 is I
wanted to play here and maybe and do
some I want to induce like this advance
but I didn't want to do it right away
because of this and then this pawn could
advance a little bit more no actually
that's faulty thinking because I have
enough support on that I was just a bad
train of thought I don't know probably
just making moves at that point you know
it's just so closed right now I have it
slightly I mean I'm the one who's still
trying to win in fact it's saying one
and a half right now with that last move
but apparently a5 is the one that's
going to hold mm-hmm what's that doing
it's planting upon another pawn fixed on
a dark square but it's securing this
king position on c6 which is super
important yeah once my King was able to
establish himself on d5 there's probably
going to be wind so it was necessary to
keep my knight out of that be Foursquare
and yeah King d5 is what's being called
for Bishop c5 even I never wanted to
have that happen now I was I wanted this
bishop to like never exchange himself
off but Bishop c5 is apparently still
going to be winning yeah this is tough
now 96 check King d6 and my king is just
too good now he's approaching these guys
would be very difficult for black to try
and hold that but we did a little bit
more shuffling I was fearful around this
moment of like falling for some mate I
didn't I don't know how like if the king
is here and the knight is here I think
that would be mate in this kind of
position but uh yeah a little more
shuffling in in the blink we end up
having this exchange but until we got
into that time pressure was pretty even
game and this final position is of
course gonna be winning but an
interesting game tough struggle out of
another different variation of the Kings
Indian defense and feel free to leave
any feedbacks feedback in the comments
section below and as always I hope you
got something on this video and I'll
catch you in the next one take care bye
you